yeah
yes
we're rolling out the green and red
shells with plenty of viewing options to
knock around this week and oh watch out
for the banana peel
oh saved you on that one on top of Mario
and his cart full of nostalgia overload
we've got a few one-word title wrecks
that all couldn't be more different from
basketball to road rage to painting plus
an rt25 celebratory pick that just Anime
leave you wanting more that was as
painful to write as it was to say Rotten
Tomatoes is taken off from the free
throw line and you know it's gonna be a
slam dunk on this week's what to watch
is coming
[Music]
anything for my brother we're going to
save him
breaking some bricks on its way into
theaters is the Super Mario Bros movie
This is the first attempt to adapt the
famous video game franchise since 1993
which was a live action offering that
felt like one big game over on the movie
side of things we don't like to talk
about that one but it is 2023 now baby
and this time it's animated and
audiences are eating it up like a red
mushroom with the audience score
currently at 96 of course Big Time
animated movies means a big time voice
cast nowadays and this one does not
disappoint I'm talking Chris Pratt as
Mario Charlie day as Luigi plus Keegan
Michael Kia's toad Anya Taylor joyous
Princess Peach Jack Black as Bowser and
Seth Rogen as Donkey Kong and according
to my fond memories of playing Mario
Kart that covers most of the major
players I think except Josh
where's Yoshi tell me Yoshi's in it and
to ensure that this beloved franchise
was adapted the right way this time
Mario Bros Creator Shigeru Miyamoto
served as a producer and leaned on the
fine folks at illumination who made the
Despicable Me films to handle the movie
making part of it smart and if it's a
hit you can be certain this is just the
start of seeing all your favorite
Nintendo properties on the big screen in
one big shared Universe where we heard
that before you would have to have a
pretty compelling pitch I can tell them
the one thing the other companies can't
compete with
our basketball Division is terrible I do
not love it and now on to another Mega
pop culture staple served up in movie
form air which tells the incredible true
origin story of the world's most famous
shoe line of all time Air Jordan posting
up strong just under 100 on the Tomato
Meter so far and certified fresh this
one has been impressing critics with
many things including its director Ben
Affleck and star Matt Damon in fact top
critic Tim grierson from screen
International called it a crowd pleaser
made with Panache and smart adding that
Matt Damon is immensely appealing and
Ben Affleck produces one of his most
irresistibly entertaining dramas and if
you're a little worried about offending
the guy behind your coolest pair of
shoes you'll be glad to know that MJ
himself Michael Jordan did meet with
Affleck prior to filming and gave it his
Blessing
they have this Serene Zen Buddhist thing
going on
[Applause]
hey
another one that's worth a slab of your
watch time this week is a new Netflix
comedy series beef obviously you're
interested now that you know it stars
Ali Wong and Steven young but when I
tell you that they play two strangers
involved in a road rage incident that
slowly consumes their lives I'm just
hoping you'll stick around to the end of
this episode before starting it and BT
dub if you need a quick education on
road rage come visit La for a few days
the series was created by Lee sung Jin
who was actually just hired to pen
Marvel Studios Thunderbolts lucky which
is good news for them because beef is
currently certified fresh hovering
around the 100 mark on the Tomato Meter
and to back this all up is top critic
Angie Han from The Hollywood Reporter
who called it a feast of sharp comedy
wild Thrills and disarming empathy
you're lucky I'm an artist instead of a
woman who says really mean things to
other women you were an artist
if you're looking to go to a special
place this weekend why not try a theater
screening the Owen Wilson comedy paint
okay first off to answer your question
no it's not a biopic about Bob Ross
rather this is a comedy where the main
character played by Owen Wilson was
inspired by Ross Wilson plays Carl
nargle and he's got an awesome van to go
along with his amazing perm and is
Vermont's number one public TV painter
until someone starts challenging the
throne kind of feeling some Anchorman
Vibes aren't you paint was written and
directed by Brit McAdams whose past work
on Tosh.0 seemingly makes him a great
fit to bring some big laughs in the
PG-13 setting I'm not a criminal
[Music]
oh that makes me sound more like a
criminal it's complicated to be an
outlaw nowadays and because we're always
looking for a reason to party around
here this final wreck comes courtesy of
Rotten Tomatoes 25th anniversary please
don't sing instead Feast your eyes on
the Japanese anime series Cowboy Bebop
it's also celebrating its 25th
anniversary this year and is considered
one of the greatest animated series of
all time it's set in 2071 and follows a
bounty hunting crew aboard a spaceship
called the Bebop its one and only season
is certified fresh at 100 on the Tomato
Meter with an audience score quite high
as well at 95 percent and with flavors
of Western Noir science fiction and more
the critics consensus calls it a
head-spinning array of genres and
references and must be experienced and
particularly for westerners it's
considered to be the Gateway Series into
the anime genre as a whole which is what
happened back in 2001 when it became the
first ever anime to appear on Cartoon
Network's late night broadcast block
call Adults Swim if you know what we're
talking about consider yourself part of
the cool Club
well there you go now you have the
answer or five answers to the question
what should I watch be sure to let us
and your fellow viewers know in the
comments what you did check out whether
it was on this list or not remember to
check out rottentomatoes.com for the
latest updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large and
seriously check out the new rt25 page
where we are celebrating 25 years of
rotten tomatoes with all kinds of stuff
including wait for it our brand new car
game putting your movie loving mind to
the test on 25 years of Tomato Meter
scores that's all for today fresh family
until next week stay fresh
[Music]